let's get magical I'm a huge fan of
Harry Potter I've often wondered what do
the stuff that they drink and Harry
Potter tastes like seriously this is
just like my whole life has been leading
to a smell mint
[Music]
Accio butterbeer works spit words Wow
well that's good okay this would go
great on a cold winter day this tastes
more like liquor than beer yeah I had
the butter beer at Harry Potter world
and they have it like shown it's like
icy there but I think it's better when
it's warm when it's with alcohol who
wouldn't want to have a first date over
a toasty glass of butter beer
[Music]
so basically this is preventing us from
turning into the werewolves that were
not that you are not I don't know if any
of the potions actually taste good they
should put some sugar in it does look
like medicine this looks like cough
syrup inside oh that's pretty good
[Music]
that's good enough for me
[Music]
looks like I'm about to start a juice
cleanse with a week grass shop in the
books Polyjuice potion tastes nasty yeah
it's disgusting it's supposed to turn us
into somebody else
if we have a little DNA inside I would
want to turn into Beyonce hands down I
guess whoever is married to Paul Rudd it
tastes like an alcoholic salad
[Music]
it's not really love is more like an
obsession just become like it's
saturated yeah that's delightful that is
like I just serve that cocktail at my
wedding oh that's so good I'm obsessed
with this
I just taste like kool-aid it's pretty
good I love could do that it tastes like
love it tastes so good would I drink
many of these no it only takes one and
to find your one true love
only want to drink unicode blood that
sounds amazing
maybe you're in full marriage this is
great oh it's it's it's punchy oh that's
pretty good start it's like lemonade oh
yeah that's a nice jewnicorn a lot of
high quality
sorry unicorns I'm gonna drink your
blood all day every day
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] God we read that passage you're
like I want to go through a day like
this is what I think like cactus would
taste like that's nice
okay we're lucky we're lucky we're in
love we're immortal we're immortal
we're we look like one another like each
other apparently we're gonna go to Vegas
ready we need more smoke Axio smoke
magic all right I'm gonna fly get em
anyway I'm gonna fly